so we've covered the basic idea that
divides the usage of v from a and an you
know and then the is the definite
article
and a or an is the indefinite
so when you're being non-specific in
language you would use the indefinite
article as in
may i have
an orange
question mark
because it doesn't matter
which orange you're asking for you don't
care it's any orange as opposed to if
you wanted
the
orange
this usage is much more specific and it
seems to indicate that there is only
one orange
you you see the orange in particular
that you want you're identifying it and
you're asking for it that's what this
definite usage is
something that's interesting about the
word the is that it can be used for both
singular
and plural
nouns
so it's both singular and plural so you
could say may i have the orange you
could also say may i have
the oranges
a and and does not really allow this it
is only singular
so you can't say
may i have
and oranges
this is this is not standard what you
would probably say instead was
may i have
some oranges
so this is
not standard
does not work in standard american
english
the other thing about a or an is that
it's a or an
the indefinite article changes depending
on the vowel sound that comes after it
so changes
for
vowel sounds now what does that mean
well it means that if you know that the
word that you're going to say next
like
then you're going to change it
to an so it's the difference between
saying
a box
and an
apple
and what we don't say in standard
american english is a apple
it's not as easy on the mouth frankly it
takes a little bit more effort and any
linguist will tell you that the way
languages develop is that they reward
laziness
so we say a box but we say an apple
something something a little weird
though you want to make sure that you're
looking for vowel sounds not just for
vowels
because some some vowels uh for example
the letter u don't always produce oo
sounds sometimes if they're at the
beginning of a word like in the word
union so if you say
a
union
that produces a yu sound and ya is
technically a consonant sound that's not
a it's not a vowel
but there are certainly cases
like
an underwater boat
where the letter u
does produce you know an ooh or an uh
sound and that's a vowel so if you're
going to start the word with a vowel
sound what you want to do is choose an
instead of a but just be careful of of
the letter u for example
so to recap
the is the definite article you can use
it for both singular and plural usage
may i have the orange may i have the
oranges a or an is indefinite and it's
only singular so you can say may i have
an orange or may i have some
oranges
before a vowel sound a changes to an
so you say a box but an apple not
a apple
you say a union but an underwater boat
you can learn anything david out